Democrats have total control of
government in New York State so
naturally they say Saturday's Chanukah
stabbing attack was the fault of
President Trump the president is a
Jewish son-in-law he speaks well of
Jewish Americans constantly he moved the
US Embassy to Jerusalem but according to
bill de blasio it's his hateful speech
that caused this attack it's not a time
for a partisan discussion but it is a
time to say some of the most hateful
speech is emanating from Washington DC
and what we need our president to do is
be a unifier a calming positive voice
reminding us of what we have in common
as Americans that's what presidents both
Democrat Republican have done for
generations we've missed that and and
the hateful speech even if it's not
inciting specific violence let's face it
we have seen these violent forces
embolden yeah that doesn't really play
here I don't think Governor Andrew Cuomo
who spent his tenure in office
demonizing pro-lifers and supporters of
the Second Amendment at the same point
of view what can anyone make of
President Trump's tweets this is how he
he plays to his partisan base by
demonizing Democrats Democrats are evil
Democrats are bad Democrats have lost
their mind their entire American you
foment that hate and then you're shocked
when you see these episodes of hate all
across the country while we're
fermenting receded to live who once
blamed white people for an attack
committed by black Israelites so-called
also decided away in against the
president quote folks still don't see
the connection with his words and how it
ignites violence he fuels people's anger
and misguided hate instead of leaving
with compassion
he simply gas lights and laughs about it
des moines bardic is a contributing
editor to National Review and
Deroy this cell this white supremacism
is really rampaging out of control in
the New York area
it is interesting when you look at the
people involved in these recent attacks
we've seen which are horrible and I hope
that they we've seen the last of them it
would be more plausible that President
Trump is appealing to white supremacist
until you actually look at the people
who engaged in these sorts of things we
had a woman named Tiffany Harris who
allegedly went up to three Jewish women
slapped him across the states across the
face and said f you Jews she happens to
be black then we have Grafton Thomas
who's the suspect in the hanukkah attack
we've just discussed earlier the machete
he also happens to be black and then we
had that awful attack in Jersey City
where he had some people go into a
kosher market and shoot up that facility
and kill a bunch of people and those
people are named David Andersson and
Francine Graham and they were black as
well so it's very odd that you don't see
the white supremacy sort of tied in the
actual suspects in these anti-semitic
attacks get real du Roi their maggots
fell off before the mug shots that must
be what's happened listen it's actually
quite disgraceful I think what's
happening here in that for example with
the Jersey City attack basically the
media were interested in that when they
thought it was some maggot guy going
nuts on Jews the minute they found out
it wasn't quite so helpful to the
narrative they just say d6 the whole the
whole thing sort of fell into George
Orwell's memory Holmes disappeared and
if it weren't for this particular attack
we wouldn't probably be talking about
the Jersey City attack and and the media
are very very good at not covering the
numerous examples of President Trump
speaking out against anti-semitism you
remember that attack at that synagogue
in Poway California near San Diego he
invited Rabbi Israel Goldstein to the
Rose Garden hugged him in public asked
him to get up and say a few words and
before he did that President Trump said
we will fight with all of our strengths
and everything that we have in our
bodies to defeat anti-semitism to end
the attacks on Jewish people and to
conquer all forms of persecution
intolerance and hate and rabbi Golson
responded I'd like to thank our dear
honorable mr. president for being as
they say in Yiddish and Mensch par
excellence that's so much coverage that
got on ABC BS and NBC naive news
programs zero so if you're a Jew who's
trembling about anti-semitism you're a
friendly Gentile who's Pro Jewish and
you're disturbed about this the words of
comfort from the press
States saying be comforted we love you
and also don't be an anti-semite that's
a bad thing
those message don't get out all of this
cover-up by the media basically play
into the hands of white supremacists
yeah they and actually it was a
fascinating series of tweets by Aaron
Bieber who is a fact checker of all
things at NBC News who says that this is
all very quote complicated relations
between the two communities between
Blacks and Jews are complicated and
basically if you guys would just put
down the machetes we could all get back
to hating Trump as one United happy
rainbow coalition
how long are people going to put up with
this nonsense it's just awful and I
think what the media need to do is be
honest about what present Trump is done
yet a Hanukkah party you guys say if
you're trying to foment hatred against
Jews you don't throw Hanukkah parties if
you hate Jews you don't let your
daughter become an Orthodox Jew and
marry an Orthodox Jew which is what she
did and and Jared Kushner is one of his
closest advisors if he hated Jews so
much he'd say get out of my White House
you're out of the will you're out of my
family goodbye it's exactly the opposite
doesn't leave the White House that Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump right beside
him going out to meet world leaders or
engage in public policy there's
something actually though creepy and
wicked about governors and mayors and
congressmen misrepresent I mean
basically de Blasio he either does this
kind of mayor of Sesame Street stuff
well Oh hate has no home in our city you
know which is twelve year old intern row
all we have this stuff where he actually
blames it on people who have nothing to
do with the event how long will people
put up with that well I don't know we
were live in New York City and we're
sick and tired of de Blasio he's very
good at one thing which is pointed the
finger never to himself but everybody
knows and it does so in this in this
case as well he's now saying
homelessness is the fault of the present
Trump as well there's sudden shortage of
Chanukah candles in this country that
that's him he's going around stealing
them all from all the God